grabbing her first meal after crossing
the polish ukrainian border katarina
jerichova looks almost relieved i took
money and my documents
and
and it's all maybe one
t-shirt the 25 year old is safe and has
plans to go to a small city outside of
warsaw but for thousands of others who
don't have set plans there are hurdles
they will face if you have a large
number of people
migrating in a short period of time
they're at risk of
infectious disease right now covet is a
big one
as the war began coveted cases in
ukraine were up
555 percent according to a u.n report
vaccination rates are fairly low at just
36 percent covet is not their main
priority right now obviously they're a
lot survival and taking care of their
kids and making sure that they get a
next meal as they flee is going to be
their main prey look paul spiegel is the
director of the center for humanitarian
health at johns hopkins on wednesday the
canadian will be flying to poland to
support the world health organization's
refugee emergency response you do
everything from tracking the actual
outbreak of surveillance to then
treatment and it's labor intensive and
that will be
much more challenging in ukraine proper
than outside
forced into tight quarters basements and
bomb shelters covid tuberculosis measles
chickenpox and even polio could threaten
lives experts say shelling has damaged
water systems and communicable diseases
are now also becoming a concern
for those who do get sick hospitals are
already overwhelmed with traumas and
access to essential medicine has
dwindled although a humanitarian
corridor has opened the need is
outpacing supply
for this 19 year old who escaped the
shock of leaving home is setting in
nothing can be important is in my family
the responsibilities host countries now
have is keeping them healthy and safe
jamie morocco global news toronto